[Music]
not-so-secret news oh [ __ ]
Timmy - detail submitted by something
behind Joe that surprised me me Bert
hell I feel like I could smell that burp
thank you a fitness tracking app expose
the location of many secret u.s. army
bases around the world oh I get it
cuz all these cats are using it and
they're in these secret bases all right
oh and it's like tracking how many steps
it is even if you're working on a
nuclear sub you gotta get your steps in
yeah what the [ __ ] do you need a Fitbit
if you're on a military base what the
[ __ ] like mandatory to work out but to
track your workout when you track it for
they'll be programming for you I feel
like some people just track how many
steps they do that day yeah or like on
their break people kind of run around
their base I know nothing about the
military of course itself I assume that
you're working out work out yeah that's
it as well
they have like a thing where it's like
you have to be in like a certain shape
quarterly or whatever it is yeah there's
like regulations for it okay q would
[Laughter]
they do but it's looser its way loose
loose area they just have to like run
five steps because some of those guys
they do when you get in but I don't
think there's like a maintenance thing
there's a maintenance thing but it's
really loose yeah and the pants are the
same as when you got in the test no it's
not the same yeah everyone exiting or
graduating the police academy they're
relatively fit and then later on the
test is so easy that everyone's just fat
afterwards yeah you get a desk job dude
it's over how would it be a desk job cop
yeah but those are that's humiliating
though is it that means you got demoted
to desk yeah it's a destitute but then
you get to Punk civilians so your your
paper jockey yeah exactly but the only
other cops will say that to you you
could Punk civilians and beat them up
all day oh wait oh I see you're saying
this you have a badness you have a gun
they don't know what you do just do some
detective if you're a police officer
yeah you still get your gun yeah if
you're actual cop everybody we mean in a
fight yeah what in case you get a meme
letter yeah yeah paper jockey
she had to flat feet well she got
promoted she got promoted oh really -
desk duty yeah well technically that's
not - she's a detective
yeah well you have it all my
understanding of cop stuff is through TV
shows and movies I mean that that to me
that's really mad all cops have to write
reports right but mess you're on the
street job yeah
no no when they're on the street
everything like every arrests every
single one they have to go back and
write a report yeah but they know but
they don't do it the cool ones no [ __ ]
that [ __ ] yeah I mean if it work that's
the real policing I heard if I was a
police officer I want to be that guy
that's in the station you know there's
always that guy this is always like this
and just walking watching people come in
and talk the [ __ ] has a mug I love that
guy just does it's like oh the guy with
the leather jacket he could wear regular
clothes and he has a badge right here on
his belt
yeah no one knows what he's doing sort
of one like this Oh what the [ __ ]
so much sergeant sergeant Doakes she's
amazing that is what the [ __ ] you
looking at the delivery guy has noticed
it what's up [ __ ] yeah exactly
he was the best person on this ship I
like you Morgan like all day with that
[ __ ] was great he was awesome supplies
[ __ ] so this app is called
Strava it's a fitness app that you can
be used with your smart phones or your
Fitbit or like fitness trackers like
Fitbit
I hope Isis is on this I mean exactly
the Russkies all these cats are like
thank God for Strava
so what are we gonna move now because we
probably should move basis who uncovered
it was it so they released this heat map
that shows like all the activity that
has ever been uploaded to the trauma
database and so they released this but
then this was released back in November
but not just recently there were
military analysts that realized that the
secret bases around the world were
exposed because of this map well that
narrows it down yeah yeah that's right -
it's generally around this area I'm like
you're right so like for example here
this is a military base in Afghanistan
and you can see the routes that people
take when they go jogging and stuff oh
[ __ ] and then
this one is in Baghdad same thing you
could see the baby I guess we're not
doing any justice by putting your ice is
might be watching this right now like I
never knew but thank you very much I get
their needs from yeah yeah like oh I
love David when he is in love with David
is on this one here's area 51 and you
can see oh [ __ ] that's dope I don't
wanted to know yeah finally you could
see that the one single person that did
maybe like a cyclist or something but
this is their route here and it's
through area 51 oh damn
and then this other one is wait I want
to see the area for do want at night
things you don't have there's only one
guy working at area 51 over this one
here is the [ __ ] Falkland Islands
payment that's a dope ass name that's a
really sick name yeah are we there we're
there - we're at the Falkland Islands we
just call it the Falklands I want to be
President just so I could go to area 51
I know I want to see all the [ __ ] yeah
do you think there's like a secret like
there like Oh after you know this
presidency whenever that area 51
incident happened they're like after us
we're not gonna tell the next guys well
I think so yeah yeah do the president I
have clearance over everything do they
need to know I heard that that even oh
god I think it was Hyson Hauer
he was like I want to know what's going
on everything you want and they're like
you don't have need to know guys that
are working there they've been there
since like five presidents ago and
they're still working yeah everything's
compartmentalized to in the military
like where is like as far as like who
knows what secrets and [ __ ] you know
it's like everyone knows all the secrets
like it's all like segmented that's
supposed to be that way
oh so then like the army doesn't know
the marine secrets and in the CIA don't
know the FBI secrets so it's all
allegedly but I think CIA knows pretty
much everybody secret or at least NSA
does do you guys all blocked the camera
on the oh hell yeah cuz after I watched
black mirror I was like ain't nobody
gonna watch me jackoff
what FBI agent yup it's about that time
I have a really kind of a weird fetish I
watch Joe Jitsu coward jerk-off it's
weirdest thing laughs I love his vlogs
but I loved watching him jack off even
more I could get anyone in the world but
only Joe Jitsu Cowell gets me there
creeps me out
that's why I don't block my [ __ ] I'm
like nobody's watching yeah yeah I want
people to tell me if I'm being watched
there's hotter people biome I'll go
watch like Brad Brad Pitt better covers
[ __ ] oh yeah are you just like do your
flap one day so you enjoyed that you
sick freak yeah no the hotties better
cover their [ __ ] but like you know well
you know what most of my exes probably
should be fine Mark Zuckerberg does it
so I was like I'm gonna do it to you
well he's a billionaire you can
blackmail as that yeah i'm a
thousandaire i could be blackmail
exactly unless say you have a really
particular fetish with you I don't think
anyone wants to see your kiss I know
people don't usually blackmail downwards
yeah but if they're really poor they're
gonna aim closer to what they can do I
like to think that if I was if I was
like a criminal right like and I'm like
I don't have I'm not a confident
criminal I'm not gonna go after
billionaires cuz they have too much
security
I'm gonna go 4,000 Aires or average
people I'm just sayin Scarlett Johansson
better freaking rip the camera out of
her laptop cuz if these cats can really
get in anywhere that's the kind of
person got to be careful I know you know
the Ryan Reynolds is right even as a man
I'd watch Ryan Reynolds jerk off of
course I close yeah like what phases
eBay yeah is it interesting
mine would just be disappointing we'll
leave it at that we don't want to go
into that you can't ask me if you want
answers anyone have any questions for me
how do you block the sound because the
the microphones and the keyboards right
so they can hear the whole conversation
now you [ __ ] it through now she's I
have to find a [ __ ] tiny cotton swab
and stick it in the thing now
oh my worry is there is a microphone I
think it's inside the keyboards yeah
funny cuz like when I see that like I
heared you know some my friends they
block their [ __ ] and they're blocking
all the things and I just tell them like
you are nobody nobody [ __ ] cares
about you you're not important oh we got
in like I don't even like you and you're
in my house right now
perfectly friends who the [ __ ] is gonna
watch well this conversation is for you
I had a buddy over would you're a cute
girl though you should cover your [ __ ]
yeah although although you don't worry
about you are you gonna like that
okay okay I'm actually doing a legal
thing your ears work so die you'd be
great I just can't get past it I can't
get past anyway no but I was I had a
friend over and he was telling me about
something Bitcoin related right and then
he saw I have an Amazon echo thing yeah
he's like oh [ __ ] dude can you hit that
button on the top makes her go red or
whatever cuz it makes her not listen to
you and so she has like a red light
around it yeah my dude named nobody
gives a [ __ ] about your shitty little
Bitcoin thing what were you guys talking
about terrorist attacks and stuff or
like things that you know he was just
talking about Bitcoin Oh like how he has
some Bitcoin one of the main things that
I think I am scared of is they can
remotely take a picture of you and then
they can use that as a way to get to do
fraud oh that's true mm-hmm that's
pretty good and I got a thousand dollars
so I'm kind of scared yeah I be worried
you can put that money in our safe if
you want I have to cash it out first
yeah you could put it in our safe okay
okay
[Music]
[Music]